you think it was gonna take a picture
you guys taking your picture anyway
video okay so you're saying is better
than my mom first meal this is the test
is the food as bad as everybody says it
is will be the judge I think she's okay
she has to come out running screaming so
I think we're good you just spent five
hundred dollars on the unlimited alcohol
package happy day two of our European
adventure today we're gonna explore
Venice a little more and hop on the
cruise ship
[Music]
so one of our policies when we travel
and do air babies is to what's our
policy clean up leave the place as clean
as it was ideally cleaner I don't do it
now hotels just air babies because you
know so give it a little surprise and
delight when they come in expecting a
huge mess look at that amazing cleaning
place that we left that we clean up and
we're gonna go ahead - I'll have some
morning Italian special keep me going
good job Nina we love you
[Music]
also quick fact Nina and I are twins
today can you spot the similarity
wearing sunglasses all right we found
our morning coffee Dolce Vita highly
recommended coffee shop here in Venice -
here give it a shot do you want sugar
[Music]
nice we've got a chocolate filled what's
out in the pistachio this one yeah how I
feeling good satisfied very satisfying
not too full just just right just right
okay next because we have luggage Nina
likes to travel
massive luggage no cuz we had to check
out of her Airbnb I got allergies from
the smoke crazy smokers here's what I
think we have our crazy luggage insane
luggage that we don't want to carry
around with us all day before we can get
on the cruise ship
so Venice is known for its canals we're
gonna hop one of the ferries and just
sit on the canal go back and forth and
then hopefully go find our cruise ship
relax relax and time in Venice the
scenic route today
let's do it every time we have to cross
these canals you think it was going to
take a picture you guys taking your
picture anyway video we're across these
canals I have to carry the suitcase
[Music]
you're a tall person doke I don't well
only when it serves me okay time for
Evan to carry the suitcase down the
stairs let's go okay back to you Nina
mm-hmm
that way to the boats to the boats
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right we hope you enjoyed those
reviews as much as we did
now we're ready to go for our last meal
in Venice a specialty Italian restaurant
and we need to take this one to the
washer okay I made it look at that smile
that's very cute when a time foods we
had we had we had the coffee way at the
pizza gelato and you Joe that's a high
five boom
all right result it is this is the
famous local drink old spritz
oh all of them laughs I can't even give
it a shot
you got your house red wine and sweet
okay try this spritz No
it's a promise you let's put a fight
yeah yeah go for it
oh my gosh oh there's no cheese on it
it's mostly only the buffer of buffalo
cheese okay make sure you get yeah yeah
no no take a good chunk of buffalo
cheese is it is it really good does it
really hit oh my god
oh my god I can smell it because bin
that is to a oh my god okay guys I got
to stop killing I got to eat this
there's our specialty risotto okay and
this is like okay so you're saying it's
better than my mom
there were you think is it worse than my
mom my mom might see this video either
way all right Nina's non-committal about
the risotto it looks good though this is
a pretty awesome last meal and actually
not even Italy because we're gonna go to
Brenda C tomorrow but last meal in
Venice
let me sound surprised
since there's our last stop I'm gonna
get a second cappuccino just because
because why not right why not you know
what
surround yourself with friends people in
your life who when you say something
they say why not I know why not instead
of why are you doing that and giving you
that judgment and that look right
instead you want friends to tell you I
know why not right Wow and so I'm having
my cappuccino why not
last meal in Venice what do you think
very satisfied filling but not too full
your fault yeah unfulfilled but not too
full
your little buzz she had my dream she's
gonna jump alcohol and haricot she's
drunk good start
are you very red actually looking out
right you are anyway enjoy our last meal
in Venice apparently apparently the food
is really bad on the boat with MSC
Cruises so that's why we had extra
special last meal in back because the
wife loves me so that means it's on me
to make sure we have good lunches in
every spot in every port right right get
on that evidence
[Music]
look what we found MSC musica
let's go Nina let's go let's get on the
boat
okay we made it time to stand in this
line alrighty we love lineups it's the
best okay good news that huge lineup is
just to drop off your luggage but we
travel light right Nina good thing you
didn't bring your crazy luggage
[Music]
all right nice it's two o'clock almost
rooms are socially ready at 2:30 this
opposed to make a big announcement
nimi didn't want to wait though it's all
thought something is right with the Nina
you want to take them on the tour yeah
okay okay who's sleeping on that this is
a unit would cut or is this did you
notice the giant mirror in front of the
bed what's that for I don't know but
Nina's real-estate agent here there's a
unit unit it's oh it's the arches in
office again okay it's a unit that's my
closet where's yours Oh what do you
think guys Nina's Nina's a real estate
agent tour guide unit shoving unit
Michelle shelfs mirror here's an office
huh huh another office unit okay that
that is tour guide with Nina and so now
now we're gonna do some admin stuff who
are gonna see is gonna be those
allergies smoking lots of smokers I'll
film something when there's something to
show how's that
they have it Sienna Nina CNN we're fresh
on vacation this is the official start
right now
[Music]
[Music]
I hope you guys are enjoying this view
as much as me we're super fortunate that
we're on the 15th or on the top deck of
this boat 15th floor up and we just
happen to be going by the beautiful of
the city of Venice on the way up super
fortunately we're on this side of the
boat and just taking it all the way it's
a view like none other that you can't
get very many places so I don't know how
well that came out on camera but I've
seen a lot of different cruise exits and
that was the most beautiful one that I
have seen so super pump what was the
other one that we had why don't we put
the fireworks and I made a rant about
that
you know Ryder damn Christina will
remember and we'll show the clip right
now
but in terms of actual like beauty that
was really spectacular and I'm really
glad that that we caught it so anyway
taking it all in
Nina and I both went for a shower and
now we are gonna go get some dinner
first meal this is the test is the food
as bad as everybody says it is
we'll be the judge take the stairs every
day on the stairs only way no elevators
here no elevators here in the go-team
Carmical
[Music]
step number one minestrone Nina says it
doesn't look that good
let's see how it tastes it's okay all
right it's an okay round two
mozzarella got the lapped a tomatoes we
both got one so let's see it Nina
doesn't look that good she's not
impressed all right Wow
last up is two chef's signature dish
pasta with seafood sauce
Nina looks very impressed
here comes how's the pasta quality Nina
here comes this is it
and
Leeson cheese yeah okay all right good
last man for me apple crumble with
vanilla ice cream nothing to Mina you
want a bite no okay first dinner done
Lena's gonna give it a score at a ten
five five it's not okay five is pretty
much you failed
normally at this time we go up to get
dessert at the bar at the nothing work
at the buffet but we're gonna go see if
we can do some dancing first and then go
to the bathroom I accidentally sent me
into the men's washroom this is the
washroom it looks like that's a woman
doesn't it with the thing on the side
it's not a woman but then on the other
side is the actual woman's time to go
there let me show you
that is the actual woman's washroom more
pronounced so I sent me into the men's
washroom I think it's only solo
something I think she's okay she hasn't
come out running screaming so I think
we're good that's the men's I said well
it looked like it was a dress that that
thing was wearing and then I came over
here like right there like oh no I just
said look Mimi for the men's washroom
but she hasn't come out running so
there's a solo at work and other people
have come in but but other people could
have come in right they would have been
the best that's my bad I'll take the El
on that one but I do secretly wish
somebody came in that would have been
that would have been amazing best
vacation ever
we love you Nina so much okay so all the
places playing really slow foreign music
as we discovered
we had four spots they all got an axe
there's one other spot that is open at
10 o'clock that seems to be younger
stuff so because we can't dance Nina
decided to do something else that was
crazy
what it need to do that was crazy Nina
just spent five hundred dollars on the
unlimited alcohol package so she better
drink a lot now even to get our new
official $500 more expensive tickets I'm
and join this join this that's the word
okay yeah first stop the bar what are
you happy what am I having
what are you
happening
doesn't look expensive enough
you got likes the party
okay chocolate mint that's my love
affair give it to me
alright celebration
[Music]
all right we're making the use of our
drink package Cheers
all right now
well delayed but we had a drink buffet
and then a dancing buffet and now it's
time for the buffet buffet I'm hoping
for some nice crumble with sauce
Nina's hoping for some ginseng tea I
made that up she really wants some
marshmallows what are you looking
forward to
soup soup we're on the 15th floor the
highest deck so we got to walk like 10
floors up that's what took you so long
Nina's got short legs but she still
takes two at a time you're Japanese
although she's holding on it's kind of
cheating but we still love you there you
go there you go work those legs Nina you
could totally fit in there can you fit
in there without ducking well it's so
close all right you're older than eleven
yes good job Nina all right taller
barely really I got the cream pizza is a
plate of fruit and they got some pea and
fish and looks like he's ordering
another drink Nina got some more red
wine and she got me something too
oh my gosh so much uh-huh that's how I
feel
[Music]
okay believe nation we're gonna head to
the room yeah and relax and yeah you
guys aren't allowed to come in with us
if you want to see why we started this
crazy adventure check the link next to
us I think you'll enjoy to believe I'll
see you there whatever you want what is
I wanted to sleep but no we can't we
can't because this is the only day we
have in Venice